so I think what what peterlee is
referring to you when you talk
and communicate with people in ways that
have the same degree of surprise that
people have when they encounter each
other and have conversations and new
conversations are developed there's
something about the way people move
through space which is absolutely unique
to them and when you can capture that
have a computer which can understand
that they learn something about
themselves that they may not have even
seen and that for me is this kind of
crucial educational moment when they
people can discover something new about
themselves that they may not have known
about before the new research I'm doing
involves eyes and how people use them
and in particular I'm interested in sort
of asking the questions you know what if
an artwork was aware how it was being
looked at one is a small robot that has
an eye and which meets the gaze of the
viewer it kind of looks you in the eye
cuz your face it engages in kind of a
blinking response to your own blinking
that may be kind of startling in uncanny
you